Okay. We've been talking basically since even
before Donald Trump was elected, about the
coalescing and catalyzing of white supremacy
and extremism in the United States. And my
general view might instinct at the beginning
was that Donald Trump is not creating white
supremacy. He's not creating antisemitism.
He's not creating bigotry. Probably. Uh, but
he is number one, sort of coalescing it. And
number two making the bigots and the white
supremacists and the antisemites more comfortable
being out in the open, being more public about
their extreme views and is getting them actually
organizing to a greater degree. Now that was
my idea early on and it does seem to be born
out including by the former and even current
white nationalists and white supremacists
that we've spoken to. I was recently reviewing
in preparation for this story, my, my interview
a couple of years ago with white nationalist,
Richard Spencer. He's someone in the movement
and again, he believes, you know, tr Trump's
not literally one of us and it's not clear
that he's creating more of us, but he is kind
of fomenting this environment in which we
are more likely to thrive or to do well or
whatever the case may be or organize.
We now have a report from the Anti Defamation
League and the report is called hate beyond
borders. The internationalization of white
supremacy and the report shows two things.
Number one, it shows that white supremacy
is under Trump, but really over the last two
years, Trump is just a piece of that, of what's
going on, being internationalized, meaning
that there are more links and and sort of
flow of white supremacist organization across
country lines including from the United States
to Europe and we'll dig into that in more
detail in a second. The other thing that the
ADL report shows is that there is also more
weaponization of white supremacy and my interpretation
of weaponization is that what they're talking
about is turning the ideas into activism.
It doesn't necessarily have to mean physical
violence, but it's the taking of the ideas
and weaponizing them by making them real activism.
This is a really well done study and it combines
sort of the political circumstances that are
fueling this as well as the technological
circumstances because that's a big thing as
well.
We recently interviewed former white supremacist,
frank mink, and he said there is now an ability
to be radicalized and to have these extreme
communities exist completely digitally, completely
over the Internet because of the technology
that exists. So I'll tell you about some of
the factors at play. Number one, the white
supremacist conference scene has grown dramatically
over the last couple of years. It includes
American and European extremists, everywhere
from Sweden, Russia and Estonia having in
person events and they are internationalized.
You have people flying all over to go to these
white supremacist events. That is one element
that is weaponizing and internationalize in
white supremacy. You have the far right nationalist
parties in Europe. Some of those parties have
ties to neo-nazis directly, a plain, plain
and simple. Others it's a little bit more
nuanced and and sort of guised but they are
serving as a sort of central point of contact
for many white supremacists that were previously
isolated.
In a sense, uh, the immigration debate in
both Europe and the United States has been
another, I guess you would call it like a
uniting issue for white supremacists who are
looking to become more active in immigration
has been an issue that has coalesced and catalyzed
a lot of that activism into something particular
a policy, a, um, um, a policy demand, so to
speak, that these folks can rally around technology.
We have to understand that the internet messaging,
Facebook, Twitter, Gab, what's app that is,
uh, enabling technology that allows these
groups and ideologies to cross country lines
far more easily. So for example, you've got
the u s based group, women for area in unity.
Yeah. They now have chapters in Europe. So
the immediate question is what is it that
needs to happen? The first thing is an electoral
prescription, which is the nationalist leaders
that are, if not directly supporting this
kind of indifferently, allowing the environment
in which this stuff grows and it becomes weaponized.
Those leaders need to be removed or stripped
of power or marginalized depending on what
the government system is. And the United States.
This includes, you've got to remove Donald
Trump period. Uh, in other countries you're
talking about representation in a parliamentary
system, in a representative system really
you have to look at the particulars, but the
leaders that are fomenting this implicitly
or explicitly have to be removed and hopefully
we will start seeing the pendulum swing swing
back in that direction in 2020. Once you cross
country lines, at least here in the United
States, it's possible to designate these groups,
foreign terrorist organizations internationally.
That may not mean much, but here in the United
States it gives the State Department and law
enforcement more resources and latitude to
fight against these groups. So that's something
that should be looked at as per the Santee
defamation League report, the technology companies.
Because remember technology is a big piece
of what is allowing this to fester foam and
grow the technology companies.
They basically already have terms of service
that apply to what it is that we are seeing.
It's more about enforcing those terms of service.
And uh, this is a much bigger issue. When
I was on the Joe Rogan program three months
ago, we talked a lot of four months ago actually,
we talked a lot about the policies themselves
versus their enforcement and sort of interrelated
issues. And this is, we could do an entire
conversation just about that and we have,
but the enforcement of these policies in ways
to limit these groups ability to recruit and
to spread their messages. That's also important.
And what we really have to understand is that
these are, there are real world effects here,
right? We are seeing terrorist incidents,
we are seeing shootings, we are seeing, uh,
Orthodox Jews being attacked out in public,
in Brooklyn and other places. We're seeing
Jewish emigration out of certain European
countries like France.
I believe going from memory, France has actually
seen an outflow of Jewish residents thanks
to the environment that is out there. So this
is not merely, it's easy to say, oh, this
is stuff that exists on the Internet period.
No, there are groups that are tracking the
real world impact and it's significant and
we're seeing this stuff pervade the judiciary.
We're seeing this stuff purveyed law enforcement
here in the United States, and this is a really,
really good study that looks at exactly how
it is being both weaponized and internationalized
by a combination of these nationalist trends
that we've been seeing combined with the technological
factors that allow it to happen. We're going
to be following up about on our Instagram
page at David Pakman show on Instagram. Make
sure you're following the show there and while
you're there, follow me as well. I posted
a picture. I am on the road, as many of you
who have been watching the show this week.
Notice I posted a selfie with a Nimo, the
Adderall dog. As some of you know him, please
don't take offense to that. It's just a joke.
Uh, and I posted a Selfie with him on my personal
Instagram this morning at David Dot. Packman
check it out. Follow me, follow the show.
We'll take a quick break and be back off.